most Easter eggs are discovered within a
few weeks or months of a videogames
release but once in a while it takes a
little longer to find some of the secret
goodies developers bury within their
products
let's put saving Hyrule on hold while we
explore some Easter eggs that were
hidden a little too well and took a
whole lot longer to find halo 3 happy
birthday Lauren during Halo 3's creation
one of the developers sneaked in a
little message that took years to find
in fact he actually had to reveal the
secret himself after seven years since
no one had found it Adrian Perez
revealed in 2014 that he hid a secret
message in Halo 3's main loading screen
the only way to get it was to set your
consoles clock to December 25th or play
the game during this actual day and
press in both thumbsticks while the game
is loading happy birthday Lauren will
appear on the loading screen if done
correctly as cool as this little gift
might be it hardly makes up for the fact
that Lauren shares her birthday with
Christmas that's the worst
The Legend of Zelda a Link to the Past
Chris Houlihan's room in 1990 Nintendo
Power ran a contest that would allow a
fan to get their name included in an
unannounced SNES game which turned out
to be a Link to the Past it was revealed
in the early 2000s that the winner was a
fan named Chris Houlihan in order to see
his name you'd have to glitch link into
a secret room full of rupees and a
plaque that featured the lucky fans name
but as having your name hidden within an
impossible to find glitch really that
much of a prize maybe Chris would have
been better off taking whatever was
behind door number 2 Final Fantasy 9 the
Nero brothers quest despite being
released in 2000 Final Fantasy 9s final
quest was found a whopping 13 years
later this quest had players
encountering the Nero brothers as they
taught sadani the finer points of
gambling what made the secret so
difficult to track down was the fact
that you had to find them throughout
multiple points in the game in order to
continue with the quests progression and
after all that work you would have
received a protect ring as your reward a
solid if not particularly rare item yay
Batman Arkham City cow
under man's creepy message in Batman
Arkham City players can visit the
villain calendar man on different
holidays in the real world to listen to
some unique dialogue after the Easter
Egg remained undiscovered for three
years Rocksteady Studios intervened and
revealed how to discover this hidden bit
of dialogue here's the trick if you set
the date on your PC or console to
December 13 2004 the date Rocksteady
Studios was founded you get a message
that references Batman Arkham Knight the
next game in the series which at the
time hadn't even been announced yet I
was there at your beginning and I will
be there that's your pen the irony of
course is that calendar man is obsessed
with dates but he'll never actually
score a date himself just look at him
Splinter Cell double agent seals
Splinter Cell double agent was released
in 2006 but it wasn't until 2010 that
players learned courtesy of one of the
developers that they could find a secret
mission to rescue baby seals wearing
party hats they're just these cute
little things with names like pepperoni
and were beamed away after being rescued
because apparently they're aliens as
well wave race blue storm sarcastic
announcer wave race blue storm featured
an announcer who would provide color
commentary whenever players performed
cool tricks on their jet skis in 2009
eight years after its Gamecube release
it was discovered that players could
input a code on the audio settings
screen in order to activate an
alternative announcer one who was
decidedly more sarcastic as he raced he
would say things like it was great Mike
Tyson's punch-out ball Bulls tell now
here is an Easter Egg that actually
helps players out in Mike Tyson's
punch-out the Easter egg involves the
fight with bald bull and it wasn't
discovered for 22 years in 2009 former
Nintendo CEO Satoru Iwata revealed that
there was an easier way to beat bald
bull that didn't require you to punch
him after his third hop in order to
interrupt his bull charge all you had to
do was look at the background and try to
spot an audience member who was taking a
picture with a flash camera once the
flash went off you could deliver a body
blow to the bowl to bring him down that
would have saved NES gamers a lot of
misery back in the 80s well better late
than never right after all the retro
gamers out there learned about bald
Bulls tell a similar trick was found for
piston honda on april 8th 2016 Reddit
user and youtuber Midwestern housewives
discovered a visual cue that can help
Little Mac beat piston honda with ease
during your world circuitry match piston
honda will go for a barrage of hits and
will back step before charging veteran
gamers are well aware that you can
counter his delayed charge during the
sequence for a knockout but you must
have precise timing similar to the bald
bull trick watch the front of the crowd
on the left side a bearded audience
member will not duck the exact moment
you're supposed to counterpunch honda
this standout spectator also does the
same thing for bald bulls charged during
your rematch with him it's crazy to
think that another punch-out secret was
hiding in plain sight until it was
discovered 28 years after the game's NES
debut thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to see more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which secrets you
think should have made this list